Although you share more traits with those relatives with whom
you're most genetically similar, let's say your parents, and your
brothers and sisters, this doesn't mean that your closest relatives
like your parents or siblings share every trait that you have.
And this diagram that we've constructed up to this point
doesn't do a very good job at revealing which family
members share which traits. Right? We're not doing a good
job of showing the relatedness of particular traits. Now, to combine
this sort of family tree with the information about
traits that we're interested in understanding, we're going to use
a very special kind of diagram called a pedigree.
Now, pedigrees are just an organized way of looking at
family relations and traits. Females are symbolized with just
a simple circle symbol and males are symbolized with
just a square. A single line drawn in between
a male and female does not indicate marriage, I repeat,
does not indicate marriage. It simply indicates that
there were sexual relations and line coming downwards and
splitting into any number of circles and squares
simply indicates the number of children and whether or
not they were sons squares or daughters, circles.
And each new generation in the pedigree gets it's
own row, so here we have the children, the
parents, the grandparents, the great-grandparents. Now none of this
is probably really unique to you from our family
tree we were looking at before, because we have the
relatedness of the family, the genetic relatedness, right? We can
see the tiers, the organization, the male-female aspect of it
but what we're missing are trait relationships. And this
is where pedigrees become immensely useful, because not only are
these shapes indicative of something about this individual, the fact
that they're male or female, but we can also shade
them in to indicate whether or not the individual has a particular trait
or not. So, let's use an example the trait of lactose intolerance. Something
we learned about in the last lesson, lesson four. Now, the way this
works, is we want to represent the trait
of lactose intolerance using our shading mechanism.
If an individual is in fact lactose intolerant, we
want to shade that individual shape, the circle or the
square and if they're not lactose intolerant, if they're
lactose tolerant, right, they can actually digest milk products,
then we're not going to shade the circle at all.
We're going to leave it empty. It really is that
simple. So let's try to build a pedigree for
a particular individual concerning the trait of lactose intolerance.
Meet Kate. Kate and her family have a European and Jewish ancestry. Kate is, in
fact, lactose intolerant but her brother is
not. Neither of Kate's parents are lactose intolerant
either but, her maternal grandfather and paternal
aunt are intolerant. Remember, maternal grandfather means the
grandfather on her mother's side and paternal
aunt means the aunt on her father's side.
Using all of this information I want you to
tell me, which of the following pedigrees represents Kate's family,
and the trait of lactose intolerance. Now only one
of these five pedigrees can be right. And the only
way you'll be able to figure it out is
if you understand what the symbols mean in the pedigree
and what the shading means. Hopefully, this isn't too
hard and go ahead and give it your best shot.